my grandfather always told me don't bet
the ranch this is a family entity there
are other members of your family that
rely upon it that's something I take
very seriously so that means you have to
be making decisions a little bit more
conservatively you have to be more
patient in your decisions and for him
that meant don't bet the ranch don't
make too big of a play yet I also think
about it today I'm 38 and in looking at
the next 25 years plus of my career and
I want to make sure that I'm in a
position and leading an organization
that I'm passionate about my name is
Ryan O'Melveny Wilson I am the chief
marketing and strategy officer of
Lowry's restaurants incorporated I
graduated from the GSB Sloan class of
2018 I'm fourth generation in the
business lowery the namesake was
Lawrence Frank
my great-grandfather when we opened the
restaurant actually in the development
of the concept my great-grandfather
wanted to serve a single entree that's
it he wanted to be one item and that
meal stayed the same until probably the
mid 80s when the first change we
incorporated on this menu was the
inclusion of sour cream on the baked
potato
today we're at Larry's prime rib Beverly
Hills it's in the midst of a whole recon
cepting revitalization in business that
business opportunity challenge I've
taken a tremendous amount of learnings
from my coursework at Stanford into how
to rebuild a business and how to make it
much more nimble and lean and that's
something I'm really excited about
I think you know particularly against
the backdrop of Silicon Valley where
everyone's expectation is something new
and different in a disruptive workplace
a disruptive company a disruptive
product there's something about coming
and working for an established brand
that I think has forgotten in that
environment
and so when I hear that adage of fail
fast I think about the idea of
constantly making evolutions in progress
in a restaurant
every single day we need to be making
some subtle change that is making the
dining experience better and so
fail-fast sounds really scary when you
look at it on a big picture and that's
something we don't do we take great
steps to mitigate against that big
picture risk but on a small scale we're
always looking to make improvements
whether it's a garnish or a presentation
or trying to sell it or a slight change
in our steps a service or a new menu
presentation I want our organization to
always be willing to make those little
changes so one of the great things about
the restaurant business it's one of the
few businesses that has such a tight
feedback loop I serve you a salad I'm
gonna know within the first couple bites
of that salad is proper temperature is
served at the proper time if the flavor
profiles right I can know very
immediately from your facial reaction
frankly I know that quality is not easy
and yet I think quality is ultimately a
differentiator and I'm not looking for
the easy fixes I'm looking for the
quality I'm looking for things that are
going to be attractive to a specific
palate specific consumer and to me
that's a defining piece of advice in a
defining element of how I make decisions
as an entrepreneur and for me and I want
to be in a position where I'm creating
new things and that's speaking to my own
motivations and I think it's really
important to express those needs and
desires rather than just be a slave if
you will to what the expectations are
I'm passionate about the food and in a
family business I think it's okay to be
explicit about what your motivations are
and what you're passionate about think
in the end that's going to make you more
comfortable more confident and being in
this role for a career I'm not going
anywhere right
I'm not looking to jump in two years
when the next best offer comes around
I'm looking at the next 30 to 40 years